haltet alle mal die fresse jetzt rede
ich über italien das matt herzig klingen
aber mein mitleid mit italien hält sich
in grenzen
die italiener haben mein leben ruiniert
von mir aus können die an trockenen
fahren italien aber wer weiß vielleicht
wird die neue regierung ja auch in zwei
drei wochen vor die wand und es gibt
neuwahlen was dann passiert ist klar der
letzte seriöse politiker europas kehrt
zurück silvio berlusconi seine partei
wollte er in pforzheim yorker umbenennen
das heißt so viel wie vorwärts muschi
ja wie denn sonst rückwärts muschi
ansonsten haben jetzt drei alternativen
alle scheiße
erstens deutschland akzeptiert dass sich
italien noch mehr verschuldet wir lassen
die miese machen bis der hugo fand
nachteil drei sekunden später kommen die
griechen um die ecke und wollen auch
nicht mehr sparen dann heißt es in athen
[Musik]
idee 2 wir lassen italien aus prinzip
pleite gehen damit sie es lernen die
spaghettis dummerweise lernen wir dann
auch was nämlich dass das eine totale
scheiße idee ist europas banken sind so
verflochten dass dann vielleicht gar
ganze euro implodiert außerdem wir
müssen ein stück welt wir können europa
nicht beherrschen da müssen wir sehr
aufpassen
die anderen mögen das auch gar nicht hat
sich rausgestellt die mögen das gar
nicht schade idee 3 wir vergessen den
euro und führen die d mark wieder ein
oder die deutsche reichsbahn keine
ahnung hatten
dieser neue währung würde brutal
aufgewertet und unser export wunder wäre
sofort komplett im arsch kurz gesagt
egal wie es jetzt kommt es wird hässlich
mein tipp lieber anleger kaufen sie sich
von ihrem letzten geld eine schöne
flasche ramazzotti und trinken die
ekelhafte per 6 dauert das noch lange
es dauert so lange wie es dauert
gernot hassknecht meine damen und herren
wir haben